speaking of that this evening it turns
out that I am one of The Debaters I will
be taking the negative on the resolution
and therefore I won't be moderating this
debate and so I must recuse myself from
that job and bring to the stage for the
rest of the evening Francis Menton who
will be moderator Francis please come to
the stage
[Applause]
well thank you so much Gene and I'm so
happy to be here many of you may know me
from my famous
blog Manhattan contrarian I hope there's
a lot of readers of that here
and if you're not a reader you should be
it's Manhattan contrarian.com
but there is one thing I'm more famous
for than that and that is being the day
out of Jane who just gave that fabulous
introduction
so uh with that let me invite our other
debater to the stage he's Andrew
koppelman
he is a J.P Stevens John Paul Stevens
professor of law at Northwestern
University
he also seems to
take part somehow in the political
science and philosophy departments there
and he is
written a recent book called Burning
Down The House how libertarian
philosophy
was corrupted by delusion and greed I
notice
that nowhere in that title is
disdain for the week which is which is
in today's resolution but with that
Andrew koppelman could you please come
to the stage
and our other debater is already on the
stage the man who needs no introduction
Mr Gene Epstein the executive director
here of the Soho forum
[Applause]
so one more time tonight's resolution
libertarianism has been thoroughly
corrupted by delusion greed and disdain
for the week and I think this is the
time to close the vote
so Jane mentioned could you kindly close
the vote she has given me the thumbs up
the vote is closed
um
so
Mr koppelman is
for the affirmative
he will have 20 minutes to establish his
case then Mr Epstein will have uh 20
minutes for the negative
followed by five minutes each of uh
rebuttal
and then there will be a question and
answer period and finally summaries from
both sides
and the debate will close
with a final vote
after that
so Mr koppelman you have 20 minutes
thanks a lot and uh thank you for having
me here I really appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you all
two libertarian factions matter in
modern American politics the ideas of
Friedrich Hayek which value markets
because they promise a better life for
everyone really has won in American
politics they're commonplace in the
Democratic party which is Major
ideological shift that almost no
Libertarians have noticed capitalism is
embraced but it has to be tempered by
regulation and redistribution not
everybody on the left accepts those
ideas but every Democratic president has
uh the Republicans once had a similar
view and some still do but the hayekians
have lost ground to a different more
extreme libertarianism which opposes
nearly everything that government does
and its most important proponents have
been The Economist Murray rothbard the
philosopher Robert nozick and the
novelist
Ayn Rand and they've shaped some of the
libertarian interventions in American
politics most prominently America's
climate policies for the last uh several
decades which have been importantly
shaped by the libertarian Charles Koch
to understand modern libertarianism you
have to understand the context in which
it began in the late 1930s the world's
most admired economic managers were
Joseph Stalin and Adolf Hitler the Great
Depression had devastated most of the
world's economy unemployment stayed very
high in the United States Great Britain
and France and meanwhile in the Soviet
Union which had always been a rural
Backwater and in Germany which had
experienced devastating and inflation
and unemployment both those countries
were booming stimulated by huge military
and Public Work spending and most of
leading American and British politicians
and intellectuals agreed the only way
back to Prosperity was a planned economy
scientifically planned even people who
are unhappy about the dictator's methods
agreed that capitalism had failed
Friedrich Hayek felt impelled to respond
he was an Austrian Economist teaching at
the London School of economics and
modern libertarianism began with his
1944 book The Road to serfdom he argued
that efficient economic decisions
couldn't possibly be made without
private property and competitive markets
Central planning would inevitably be
both inefficient and tyrannical
capitalism is valuable because price
mechanisms transmit more information
than any Central planner can possibly
know markets can generate astonishing
levels of prosperity and offer more of
that prosperity to the least advantaged
people than socialism could and it's
turned out that Hayek was right about a
lot of things there are a huge range of
policies that were once unquestioned
tariffs for all major industries
subsidies for failing Industries wage
and price controls price supports for
Farm Commodities they're generally
agreed to be counterproductive and
wasteful even the ones that we still
have people don't seriously defend them
anymore they're just powerful interests
that manage to get them uh and Todd it's
been a fabulous success uh after the
collapse of Communism and the
abandonment of socialism by Major powers
like India the proportion of the world's
population living in Desperate poverty
has plunged now of course this uh has
had losers most prominently the
semi-skilled workers whose wages became
unsustainable in the face of competition
from poorer countries
globalization produced so much wealth
that those people could have been made
better off as well the fact that it did
not was the product of political choices
that could and should have been
different
Hayek's view in the road to serfdom
didn't entail minimal government it
imposed strict conditions on
Intervention in the economy he thought
that regulation is appropriate to deal
with what economists call externalities
side effects on third parties that
aren't reflected in prices like
pollution government should prevent
fraud should prevent manipulation uh it
should fund public goods that the
private sector won't adequately provide
roads education Social Services basic
scientific research
uh his aim is to assess the advantages
of Market including the inequalities
that markets uh engender and or ask for
some justification for interference with
those mechanisms uh but uh it does aim
to redistribute in ways that minimally
impact markets the presumption of
non-interference can be overcome with
evidence so for example there's no
reason to think that Medical Care is
going to be distributed in an equitable
way he thought that government could try
to intervene to prevent misfortunes that
people couldn't anticipate like disease
in his 1960 book The Constitution of
Liberty he actually gives you the
outlines of Obamacare
he says you know we can have uh medical
care but let's not have a National
Health Service like Britain let's give
people subsidies to buy insurance on the
private market and then of course you're
going to have to require everybody to
have insurance you're going to have to
require insurers to ensure everybody
even people who are frail and sick and
by the time you're done with that
discussion Obamacare is essentially what
you have
now that's not the only variety of
libertarianism that's out there what
I've described again turns out not that
much daylight at least with respect to
the extremely fraught issue of Obamacare
not so fraught anymore for some reason
but it was pretty fraught uh not that
much daylight between Hayek and what the
Democratic party was actually pushing uh
but there are other varieties of
libertarianism out there uh rothbard and
Rand nozick these folks are romantic
individualists they don't do cold
economic calculations like Hayek uh
they're driven by ideals of personal
Liberation and the argument is based on
rights instead of uh presumption against
interference with markets they posit an
absolute bar property is sacrosanct
anything that in feebles the state is
good for Freedom the weaker the state is
the Freer we are
uh rothbard's philosophy is the most
influential of the three and lots of
people who wouldn't recognize his name
uh Embrace his views in some detail
whatever government does even police
protection could be provided better by
private businesses markets reward those
who look after themselves taxation is
theft he surrounded himself with young
libertarian intellectuals notably nozick
who uh was uh still a student when he
came under rothbard's influence Randy
Barnett The Mastermind of the challenge
to Obamacare and uh Charles Koch who he
persuaded to found the Cato Institute
I
the uh problems with the philosophies
offered by these guys uh I'm not going
to be able to walk through their
philosophical arguments and show why the
philosophical arguments are bad I do
that in my book which provoked this
debate uh Burning Down The House uh so I
can only offer you a promissory note
here uh I will argue that these guys are
not very good philosophers and an even
worse philosopher is Ayn Rand who
reaches the same minimal State
conclusions which she defends in
apocalyptic terms so she writes that any
interference with markets is going to
elevate the cower the fraud and to Exile
from the human race the hero The Thinker
the producer the inventor the strong the
purposeful the pure and she's certainly
the most widely read libertarianism her
influence has been cited by Donald Trump
Paul Ryan many others and her arguments
matter less than her portrayals of of
Good and Evil in her novels all three of
them think that the poverty of people
who don't prosper in an unregulated
economy is simply Justice
uh that we really need to redistribute
upward to cut Social Services in order
to ease the burden of Taxation on the
richest citizens this view is prevalent
enough now that there's a serious danger
that the federal government is going to
stop paying its debts because people who
believe this have enough power in the
federal government today to keep it from
happening
none of them understood markets well as
well as high act did all of them are
relying on philosophical premises that
crumble under even brief scrutiny
a big problem for all of them is
externalities like pollution Rand never
seriously addressed the problem rothbard
thought about it a lot but his response
is radically unstable it oscillates
between either externalities have to be
tolerated wholesale because the state
can't price them which he sometimes
argues or most of modern industry has to
be prohibited because it affects
trespass on property another idea that
he entertains although there he also
suggests that
will invent substitutes for fossil fuels
very quickly so catastrophe won't follow
uh nozick is the most sensible of the
three he thinks that a society should
permit those polluting attitudes
activities whose benefits are greater
than their costs
now that starts to sound a lot like
Hayek but it's not rights-based anymore
now we're trying to think about how you
police externalities in order to make up
for the failings of markets and if you
are going to do that and police the
externalities of pollution in a
competent way it turns out that you need
an enormous scientific bureaucracy in
order to do the policing to figure out
which chemicals cause which Harms
all of them are making the same mistake
they have an excessively crude
understanding of their core concept
which is private property all of them
imagine it to be absolute dominion over
some part of the World unencumbered by
affirmative duties or a liability to
taxation but property rights have never
been like this they think they're
defending existing property rights but
this is an otherworldly fantasy property
rights have always been burdened in
various ways with responsibilities to
other people and if what you value about
property is that it gives people
Independence and autonomy then that
functions nicely performed by streams of
government generated income Social
Security or Medicare being the most
obvious examples
libertarianism is also susceptible to
abuse by Predators wealth in the United
States is increasingly concentrated at
the top economic risk has been shifted
from Broad Social Insurance to workers
and their families jobs are less secure
a college degree no longer reliably
guarantees middle class status in any
year 10 to 20 percent of Americans are
going to experience a 25 drop in their
income about a third of those don't
recover their prior level even a decade
later now some of the growth at the top
is the product of legitimate operation
of markets the astounding wealth of
Steve Jobs or Bill Gates is a small
fraction of the value that they created
uh billionaires as when they produce
value through the honest operation of
businesses when they innovate they tend
to capture about two percent of the
value that their Innovation produces so
Hayek offers you good reasons to think
that it's good to have billionaires I'm
going to disagree with Bernie Sanders
about this uh but and uh but some of the
inequality is the consequence of a crony
capitalism in which large corporations
and banks have used their power to skew
the rules toward themselves and liberals
and Libertarians ought to be able to
join forces against this but that
requires that we treat the present
distribution of wealth as uh something
other than neutral or natural
the most important of these Bandits is
the fossil fuel industry which has
deployed libertarian rhetoric to make
the Republican Party the only major
political party in the world that has
denied climate change science
and this license to profit by hurting
people and destroying their property
portrays the most basic commitments of
even randian libertarianism
if the minimal prohibitions of force and
fraud were enforced inequality at least
to the extent that it's the product of
this kind of fraud would at least be
ameliorated but that's a reason for
these leeches to try to make sure that
these rules aren't enforced at least not
against themselves and so quite a lot of
the political movement to constrain the
administrative state to constrain
Regulators to limit the power of the
Environmental Protection Agency or the
occupational safety and health
administration uh is saw there precisely
in order to benefit these uh people who
Libertarians ought to look at pretty
much the same way that they look at
failing industries that are asking for
subsidies
uh hostility to government has also
crippled public services that capitalism
needs in order to operate uh it is
fairly miraculous that in infrastructure
Bill finally got through Congress uh
it's not an accident that it took a
Democrat to get it through because you
are absolutely opposed to massive
government involvement in the economy
then it's hard to get enthusiastic about
uh roads Bridges funding for medical
research funding for basic science uh
and so again it's not an accident that
uh the pandemic response team in the
federal government was disbanded by
Trump uh as it happens uh shortly before
the disaster happened uh because when
you go looking to cut government given
that there are lots of powerful
interests that uh
are backing this or that government
program uh what you are going to end up
cutting is programs that don't have
powerful protectors that don't have uh
that benefit everybody in general and
nobody in particular
uh so all of this is Stan self-defeating
even from the selfish standpoint of
business which depends on functioning
infrastructure
uh it is I think curious that this
philosophy has captured the imagination
of so many billionaires uh whom Charles
Koch has gathered into a powerful
fundraising Network
in most times and places wealthy Elites
are conservative in the old-fashioned
sense they fear change they want to keep
Society operating along traditional
lines social welfare programs were
invented by Otto von Bismarck in the
19th century to pacify the working
classes but in America Bismarck would be
in the marginalized Centrist wing of the
Republican party which has become the
party of upheaval and revolution
and I think the recklessness is evident
in the Crusade against Obamacare you
need to embrace a mighty tough
libertarianism in order to cheerfully
strive to take Health Care away from 20
million people
the most consequential effect of
libertarianism under Coke's leadership
has been the spread of climate change
denial and the effective blocking of any
coordinated effort to address the
greatest danger that the human race has
faced in Millennia uh the federal
government started taking this seriously
during the first George Bush
Administration and mobilization by Coke
and uh his people managed to prevent it
from happening we would be living in a
very different world if you had been
able to pass a climate of carbon tax in
the 1990s
if the hollowing out of the state allows
economic behemoths to do whatever they
like that what libertarianism licenses
in the Garb of Liberty is crass
predation and the creation of a new
aristocracy the hamstringing of
environmental regulation empowers a
small group of industrialists to impose
massive costs on the rest of humanity
this is just another kind of mooching
and looting it is a new road to serfdom
it reinforces the prejudices of the
people on the left who repudiate
capitalism the Libertarians who embrace
it thinking that they are thereby
promoting Freedom are useful idiots like
the idealistic leftists of the 1930s who
hated poverty and racism and embraced
Stalin
John Galt is a sap
even in its most attractive form
libertarianism is an inadequate
political philosophy rights depend on a
culture institutions even individual
personalities that sustain them in order
to be free to live the lives they want
people need more than a minimum State
libertarianism points Beyond itself
freedom is not the absence of government
it is the capacity of people to shape
their own lives libertarianism at its
core is a protest against the massive
apparatus of Regulation and
redistribution that arose in the 20th
century that apparatus has done a lot of
stupid things and uh you know you all
have copies of Reason magazine sitting
around your chairs reason magazine is
right about a lot of things government
does it's not hard to find stupid things
that government has done but without
that apparatus we would be less free
professors like me aren't active in
politics we sit in our offices and we
write about ideas what we can do what we
the useful thing we can do is clear up
ignorance and confusion the prevalence
of bad libertarian philosophy has given
me an opportunity to make myself useful
bad political philosophy can kill you
what I try to do in the book is offer
for the poison of libertarianism a kind
of Narcan
thank you
thank you Professor koppelman for that
excellent
opening statement Mr Epstein
the floor is yours
20 minutes
uh thanks uh well the title of Andrew's
book
Burning Down The House was inspired by a
story about a fire department that
allowed a house to burn because the
homeowner hadn't paid his bill this was
meant as a lesson about market failure
in this vital area
but reasons nicolespie pointed out that
the fire department that allowed the
house to burn was run by the government
Gillespie then cited a privately run
fire department that has a specific
policy of not allowing houses to burn
under the same circumstances
applying that point more generally I
propose to defend the following
resolution
Libertarians play an important role in
objecting to the delusion greed disdain
for the weak and destruction of Life of
human life and Liberty that has
corrupted the actions of the U.S
government in important ways if I can
convince you of that resolution logic
will compel you to vote against the
resolution defended by Andrew
in covering this subject Libertarians
draw on the public Choice School of
politics which emphasizes that people in
government have the same self-interest
as uh as those of us outside government
politics it's been summarized as
politics without Romance
politics without romance includes crony
capitalism the Unholy alliance between
big business and government and includes
regulatory capture the tendency for
Regulatory Agencies to be captured by
the businesses they're meant to regulate
usually to hinder competition
Libertarians also drawn this Insight
from free market Economist Thomas Sol
quote the first lesson of Economics is
scarcity There Is Never Enough of
anything to satisfy all those who want
it the first lesson of politics is to
disregard the first lesson of Economics
unquote and Libertarians of course
believe that quote power tends to
corrupt and absolute power corrupts
absolutely
I'll be focusing on topics mentioned in
Andrew's book and for the sake of time
we'll be forced to cover each only
briefly we can delve more deeply into
any of them during the Q a
Andrew said in an interview quote a
large part of what the state does is
protect us from forces that you need the
state to control such as covid unquote
but the experience with the government's
management of the kobit pandemic
suggests the very opposite
we had a pretty good example of power
corrupting pretty absolutely when Health
official Anthony fauci kept declaring in
public interviews that quote if you
criticize me you're criticizing science
unquote
there was similar Corruption of power
when Health official Francis Collins
privately ordered that quote three
Fringe epidemiologists unquote be given
a quote quick and devastating takedown
unquote for publicly dissenting from the
lockdowns imposed by government during
the covet pandemic these three Fringe
epidemiologists happen to be from
Harvard Oxford and Stanford one of them
Stanford University epidemiologist Jay
bhattacharya publicly declared quote the
lockdowns are the single worst Public
Health mistake in the last hundred years
we will be counting the catastrophic
health and psychological harms imposed
on nearly every poor person on the face
of the Earth for a generation at the
same time they have not served to
control the epidemic in the places where
they have been most vigorously imposed
unquote
compare the outcomes in U.S states and
in Nations that had strict
government-imposed lockdowns with States
and Nations whose governments did far
less and you find no evidence that the
lockdowns made any significant
difference but there is ample evidence
of damage and destruction to life
liberty and health from the lockdowns we
have the appalling spectacle of the
government ordering nursing homes to
accept infected covert patients with
further infections resulted in massive
deaths and the comic relief of a parade
of politicians caught personally
violating their own lockdown policies
like so many thuggish buffoons the main
takeaway was that we need to avoid the
top-down intervention of government's
Central planners when a pandemic hits or
the same tragedy will repeat itself
the one referenced in Andrew's book to
the U.S government's many murderous Wars
of choice occurs in his parenthetical
statement about quote clumsy disasters
such as Vietnam Iraq and Afghanistan
unquote since clumsy disasters implies
that these disasters were unintentional
it's not quite the word President
Eisenhower would have used it would have
used when he warned about the quote
grave implications of the
military-industrial complex as
Eisenhower noted quote the potential for
the disastrous rise of misplaced power
exists and will persist a statement that
has proved grimly accurate the U.S Wars
of choice have killed millions in the
last two decades alone
on the 9 11 attacks on the U.S
libertarian Congressman Ron Paul
declared quote they don't come here to
attack us because we're rich and we're
free
they attack us because we're over there
when he called for complete withdrawal
of U.S troops from the Middle East
Ron Paul's statement was ignored by
Barack Obama who gets a general thumbs
up from Andrew
Obama continued the wars in Iraq
Afghanistan and Somalia and started Wars
in Pakistan Yemen Libya and Syria Obama
maintained a secret kill list murdered
American citizens and in Syria he armed
Rebels directly affiliated with Al Qaeda
in his presidential campaign Ron Paul
abdicated the abolition of the Federal
Reserve
but contrast Andrew endorses the Federal
Reserve commenting quote the ability of
the central bank to intervene softened
business Cycles throughout the 20th
century with less oscillations of boom
and bust unquote
Andrew's statement for which he cites no
source is a myth the period before the
1913 creation of the Federal Reserve was
not at all a period of Free banking but
one of extensive government control that
caused instability but if you include
the entire 20th century as Andrew does
business Cycles have been more severe
since the Fed was created but even if
you just take the past half century
since the early 1970s business Cycles
have been at least as severe as the
period before the Fed was created based
on insights credited to Frederick Hayek
The Economist Andrew endorses when he
won the Nobel prize in economics the
central bank is a major cause of boom
and bust
the Federal Reserve has also brought the
ravages of price inflation with which
the economy was largely spared prior to
the fed's creation there has recently
been a Plunge in the average workers
real wage as the declining purchasing
power of the dollar hammers nominal
gains in wages an inflation caused by
the surge in the purchase of treasury
debt by the fed's money printing the
fed's money printing brings up an evil
perpetrated by the central bank that any
small D Democrat should object to the
anti-democratic enlargement of
government's power over the public purse
governments normally have two ways of
raising money through taxes or through
borrowing against future taxes but
governments long ago found a third a
third way Finance operations through
money printing a function the Central
Bank performs quite efficiently
when the government need not obtain its
funds from the people but can instead
Supply the people with funds observes
libertarian Economist George riesman it
can no longer be viewed as deriving its
powers and rights from the people
unquote
in his book Andrew mentions the evil of
crony capitalism just as he did in his
talk earlier but he falls far short of
exploring the full implications he
correctly writes that quote much of the
new inequality is not the effect of
competitive markets but other chronic
capitalism in which large corporations
and banks have used their power to skew
the rules in order to redistribute
wealth toward themselves unquote Andrew
calls for liberals and Libertarians to
join forces against this but then he
strangely asks the Libertarians quote
not treat the present redistribution of
wealth as neutral or natural unquote but
Libertarians are the last ones to treat
the effects of crony capitalism as
neutral or natural the Federal Reserve
that Andrew regards as an asset is a
crony capitalist institution in League
with major Banks nor does Andrew mention
the compelling evidence that much of the
greater inequality in labor compensation
can be traced not to the free market but
to the increased role of government and
thwarting the mobility of Labor in the
free market via crony capitalism take
government's imposition of needless
licensing requirements that make it
costly in terms of time and money for
workers to switch to higher paying jobs
the percentage of workers subject to
such requirements has jumped from 10
percent in 1970 to nearly 30 percent
today and two-thirds of the increase has
spread to more occupations virtually all
of them covering jobs that the less
educated could take then there's the
other far more destructive way in which
government has been impeding the
mobility of workers this is the
accelerated rise since the 1960s in
government imposed rules regs and
restrictions that have made it
increasingly expensive to build housing
in high-wage areas like New York and San
Francisco the resulting scarcity of
supply has driven up the price of
housing in these areas making it
increasingly costly for low-wage workers
to move to these areas and to take
advantage of the higher wages
a welfare state does not necessarily
impair the workings of markets Andrew
writes and there is no real trade-off
between them unquote
but the labor markets the key mechanism
by which people climb out of poverty
have been impaired to the point of
dysfunction by the U.S welfare state
according to a study of this subject
quote in 1967 68 percent of adults 18 to
65 in the bottom quintile had jobs but
by 2017 that percentage had dropped by
almost half to 36 percent
as the study also notes as the study
also notes jobs were plentiful in 2017
as plentiful in 2017 as they were in
1967 and as the study notes quote only
one structural change can explain the
major decoupling in low-income
households of work-aged persons from
work the near quadrupling and constant
dollars of government transfer payments
to lower income households unquote well
some might applaud the generosity of our
government others might point out that
its welfare state has promoted poverty
by fostering a culture of dependency
Libertarians credit the civil rights
laws with ending Jim Crow laws imposed
by government itself but Andrew goes
much further he credits the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 with quote a massive
increase in the incomes of black
Americans he dismisses as a quote Rosy
scenario the idea that the private
sector could have played a role as he
observes this was a quote strategy that
had been attempted for nearly a century
without success unquote
countering that myth Thomas Sowell
writes quote despite the grand myth the
black economic progress began or
accelerated with the passage of the
civil rights laws and War on poverty
programs of the 1960s the poverty rate
among blacks fell from 87 percent in
1940 to 47 percent by 1960 before any of
those programs began over the next 20
years the poverty rate among blacks fell
another 18 percentage points compared to
the 40-point drop in the previous 20
years a slower rate of progress not the
economic Grand Deliverance proclaimed by
liberals the number of blacks and
professional Technical and other
high-level occupations more than doubled
in the decade preceding the Civil Rights
Act of 1964.
on a social pathology
fostered by these programs Soul observes
quote most black children 78 percent
were being raised in two parent families
in 1960 while 30 years later 66 percent
weren't being raised by a single mother
if massive programs are the only hope to
reduce crime why was there so much less
crime long before anyone ever thought of
these programs unquote
the government's welfare state is also
diminished the greatest
anti-poverty program ever devised the
free immigration of the world's poor to
the U.S where they find jobs that earn
them a Quantum Leap in income as the
libertarian Economist Milton Friedman
pointed out legitimate concern about
about immigrants potential claim on the
on the welfare state
a claim on the welfare state fuels
opposition to the free immigration that
prevailed in the early 20th century
Andrew writes about climate change but
the dissenting view taken by
Libertarians has also been taken by
non-libertane climate scientists a book
on this subject called unsettled has
been written by New York University
climate scientist Stephen coonan who
served under President Obama as under
secretary for Science and who identifies
as a lifelong Democrat kunin is far from
being climate change denial higher but
in debating another claim that
scientists still took the negative on
the debate resolution about doing a
whole lot about greenhouse gas emissions
in his rebuttal coonan stated that the
proposition of making large and Rapid
reductions in greenhouse gas emissions
is Fantastical we can't do it he added
the proposition is immoral we shouldn't
do it on the point about morality and
practicality a reporter for the
non-libertarian New York Times writes
about India quote with its 1.4 billion
inhabitants India has a need for cheap
oil to lift Millions out of poverty then
that need is
non-negotiable unquote
Andrew celebrates Obamacare as having
quote built upon Medicare and Medicaid
speaking of Libertarians opposition to
it Andrew sarcastically observes you
need to embrace a mighty tough
libertarianism in order to cheerfully
strive to take Health Care away from
millions of people but Andrew himself
has unintentionally embraced the
overwhelming likelihood that many
millions more will be denied Health Care
once runaway spending on these programs
becomes unaffordable even by a
profligate government that's the
constant warning from the nonpartisan
non-libertarian Congressional budget
office this government agency keeps
forecasting that soaring debt and
deficits of the federal government will
eventually Force Major cutbacks in
spending and it keeps singling out
Health Care spending and Social Security
as the major drivers of spending in its
forecast the agency assumes that all
other federal spending will decline as a
share of GDP and IT projects Federal
revenues to be at least as high as a
share of GDP as they ever were over the
past 75 years that's why in its
periodical studies of reducing the
federal deficit this government agency
highlights proposals for cutbacks in
health care spending the the thus
embracing the very thing that Andrew
decries as a former Congressional budget
office director once put it in Blunt
terms that Federal government's budget
is on the road to Hell there was no
polite way to describe why the world's
largest economy has placed itself on a
trajectory that looks like a third world
debt crisis our current system promises
to take care of generations of elderly
Americans but will have no choice but to
reneg on those commitments instead of
being honest with those who might
otherwise prepare now for their
retirements it's running an
intergenerational Ponzi scheme the same
crime as Bernie madoff's but worse by
orders of magnitude
Andrew has good intentions he should
join Libertarians in endorsing the
proverb the road to hell is paved with
good intentions
thank you if I have another minute to go
another minutes ago only want to say
that from what I've said I couldn't
possibly have converted any
non-libertans in the audience to a
libertarianism only want to remind you
of the thesis I as a Libertarian I'm not
thoroughly corrupted by greed I as a
Libertarian I'm pointing to the fact
that the government needs fixing in
major major ways that the Democrats that
Andrew espouses and supports are simply
blind too thank you again
[Applause]
thank you Mr Epstein and now Mr
koppelman you have five minutes for a
rebuttal I
thought so libertarianism I've said
comes in flavors some more bitter than
others uh and uh the uh varieties that I
was specifically attacking were the
rights-based uh varieties that don't
really aren't concerned about
consequences uh somebody like Murray
rothbard or uh Ayn Rand or Robert nozick
thinks that uh just having big
government violates people's rights it
doesn't matter what the consequences are
uh Gene is not that kind of libertarian
uh what EV all of the arguments that uh
he made are based on the bad
consequences of this or that government
program and I you know one of the things
I emphatically do not aim to do in the
book is defend everything that
government does uh and type say in the
book that a valuable thing that
Libertarians do is they call attention
to the dysfunction of this or that
government program very much much like
if you imagine a doctor who really
thinks that medical intervention is
never any good and that the body can
heal itself and goes looking for
evidence that this or that therapy is a
bad idea uh sometimes he would be a
fabulous medical researcher it sometimes
turns out to be true uh if you have
let's say you know a you know arthritis
in your knee and unfortunately
autobiographical example uh it turns out
that you know physical therapy is just
as good as surgery there's been a lot of
unnecessary surgery here so uh but on
the other hand you know somebody who
thinks that medical intervention is
never appropriate you don't want him as
your doctor
because you know it as it's an over
generalization
this here or there uh the public school
choice of politics that uh says well you
know government tends to be captured uh
you can't trust government it's a
valuable hypothesis it's sometimes right
but uh sometimes you know I spent some
time living in Washington DC you run
along the Potomac you are when I lived
there you were warned not to get too
Near That Water it's so polluted you
don't want to breed the fumes coming off
of that water uh today they're talking
about putting beaches on the Potomac
because uh they've done such a good job
of cleaning up the water the private
sector does not have an incentive to
control its own pollution because
ordinary tort suits can't control them
because it's hard to prove what caused
which harm only government regulation
can uh provide you with that or another
example of massive government regulation
you know I talk in the very conclusion
of the book about covid and there are
really bad examples of government
dysfunction it's one that I don't that
Gene didn't mention the Centers for
Disease Control very early on when you
wanted a test against covid the Centers
for Disease Control came up with its own
test which was no good and wouldn't let
anybody else develop their own tests
it's horrible on the other hand the
private sector wouldn't have developed a
vaccine all by itself because it
required too much investment the
investment was too risky the reason why
we got a vaccine which makes it possible
for us to be in this room together today
is because government embarked on a
massive funding of research that
produced the vaccine
there are uh I'm going to agree with a
lot of his examples there are needless
licensing requirements uh housing
restrictions do drive up the price of
housing uh the uh on the other hand uh
with respect to climate change uh it
just isn't the case the third world
countries can't develop without massive
increases in their greenhouse gas
emissions The Economist magazine that
famous proponent of the free market has
concluded that a lot of the developing
countries have managed to grow
enormously while reducing their carbon
footprint it is possible to do both at
once
uh and quite a lot of these programs the
kind of spending that he's worrying
about these programs can be made more
efficient but the libertarian attack on
Obamacare was fundamentally based on the
idea that it is morally wrong to raise
taxes in order to pay for the health
care of people who can't afford it
themselves that's the moral question
that divides me from the nozikians and
the randians that is the variety of
libertarianism that is most dangerous
[Applause]
Mr Epstein five minutes
well uh let me remind you of the
resolution uh libertarianism is
Thoroughly corrupted uh thorough means
me as well uh because uh I'm part of I'm
part of that thoroughness uh Andrew is
quite corrected in your favorites excuse
me I I I got guys I'd like I'd like 20
seconds back of my five minutes uh
please uh you know give him 40 seconds I
think the moderator's gotten a little
corrupted uh there uh so so let me
resume start from the top give me those
five minutes again back as a penalty
marker for you guys uh but that aside
obviously Andrew is quite right that I
focused on consequentialism you know we
can't we can't give a full lesson
libertarianisms in ins and outs Andrew
himself said he couldn't take a deep
dive into and into a philosophy I talked
about all the consequentialist issues
that are on the table for those
Democrats president of Obama whom Andrew
apparently regards as a perfect melding
of Hayek and responsibility as I
mentioned Obama specifically and I
mentioned not trivial issues issues of
life and death massive Killing been
recently estimated that the wars of the
last 20 years have cost four million
lives the lockdowns caused life in a
major way of the the destruction of of
children's learning this is Major harm
this this is a conflagration the the the
the U.S budget is on the road to hell
and Andrew might say well Obamacare is
good it's unaffordable as the
non-libertian Congressional budget
office keeps saying with respect to
vaccines the vaccines as you probably
know was supposed to prevent
transmission and they they dismally
failed to do that they apparently helped
keep certain people alive after the
government had killed so many in this
state and in other states of the Union
by forcing infected people to go into
nursing homes and had there not been an
FDA of Food and Drug Administration
which has been indicted for years by the
public Choice Theory as basically
ironically delaying drugs the vaccines
could have come out there could have
been all kinds of ways in which all the
knowledge that we have from the bottom
up could have been used in uh in
managing the pandemic and God forbid
that we have another one because
apparently the government is planning
the same awful destructive murderous
policies so we're talking about
something pretty major oddly enough with
respect to The Economist magazine I've
long felt it's the most overrated
magazine in the world it it's it's
basically consists of a lot of but a lot
of head out there bought Brits who who
so so added why don't they just call up
call up people in India just read the
New York the Indians the Chinese then
the Chinese the Africans they are
building coal-fired plants as fast as
they can install them they they look at
the U.S and they recognize the insanity
about what the US is doing we we consume
30 times the fossil fuels they do they
are dying of of burning dung in their
homes the the introduction of fossil
fuels over the over the last 30 years in
these countries has saved lives over and
over again they know full well that that
it's immoral to do without fossil fuels
and that fossil fuels are at least the
wave of the future over the next 30
Years and as coonin again an Obama
appointee points out we've had two
degrees of global warming and the world
is a much better place in every
conceivable way of human flourishing we
fewer people die from from from climate
disaster from tornadoes and hurricanes
than ever before we've had two degrees
of warming and we're doing far better
another two degrees if past behavior is
any prediction the future Behavior we'll
deal with the next two degrees so there
is indeed a mass Insanity in this
country with respect to the policies of
our government well the Indians and the
Chinese it even quoted in the New York
Times and the Africans recognize that
they are not going to go with the
philosophy fossil fuels for me but not
for thee they are appropriately scornful
of all those rich people who fly around
their private jets leave leaving
enormous carbon front prints and
preaching to the poor people of the
world that you can do without fossil
fuels so consequentially we Libertarians
have an important message to convey and
even by the way recognize that Andrew
Reed for a new Liberty by uh by Murray
rothbard there was an awful lot of
consequentialism in that book as well
again I'm not going to convert you or
Andrew to being libertarian if you're
not a Libertarian now I'm only trying to
tell you listen to us Libertarians
because we have an important message to
convey to you about a whole range of
important issues involving life liberty
and mass death thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you Mr Epstein so we have now come
to the question and answer portion of
the program uh
Mr Charlie Friedberg will be handling
the microphone you can line up over
there but but before we get to audience
questions the first phase of question
and answer will be between the panelists
you can each have one question to ask
the other
um
now I should think of who should go
first uh why don't you go first Mr
koppelman
I haven't got a question so you while
you think about it we'll keep you busy
answering his question
Andrew Andrews answered all my important
questions and so uh we can leave it to
you moderates prerogative buddy well the
moderators prerogative oh I just happen
to have come prepared with a whole
collection of questions
I will respect the audience but we have
uh 30 minutes for this so I might take
five or ten of that so why don't I mean
but I've got questions for both so Mr
koppelman let me go first with you
uh when when I was a kid the the welfare
and redistribution programs in this
country including Social Security and
Medicare which were the only big ones
that existed then
um
we're about five percent of GDP uh and
today uh if you include federal state
and local the Federal
redistribution programs and Welfare
programs of every variety are up to over
15 percent maybe 17 state and local adds
another five so we're up to 22 percent
of GDP uh
20 plus trillion we're talking five
trillion dollars a year here
um
is that enough or do you do you think it
should be more do you have any limit in
mind as to how far this should go or or
is there a huge amount that isn't really
needed in there that ought to be pushed
back on what what's your view on that uh
my view is that uh there's a
considerable amount of cludge in uh all
of these programs they accumulate over
time they badly need reform the
threshold question that was raised by uh
Liberty at least the libertarian
challenge to Obamacare is whether this
kind of redistribution is morally
appropriate in the first place once you
get and uh if we're going to uh talk
about the empirics one of the
consequences of Market pressures is that
the proportion of American workers in
the bottom quintile it's my by not on
it's uh
so one consequence of uh the
of Market pressures at the time that
Obamacare was enacted was that uh in the
bottom quintile of workers we're not
talking about people on welfare we're
talking about people with jobs the
proportion who didn't have health
insurance coverage from their jobs had
risen from I think it was around 20
percent in 1980 and it had risen to 40
percent and was continuing to rise we
were seeing more and more people without
inch without having any kind of health
insurance and that number was going to
continue to grow
so now Obama decided that it was going
to be such a politically heavy lift to
broaden coverage that he didn't do
anything about the inefficiencies at all
and there are massive inefficiencies the
United spends about 18 percent of gross
national product on health care about a
third of that is wasted there are things
that we could be doing to clean up the
delivery of those services without
cutting off anybody but I so Obama just
didn't try I think that it's going to be
tough enough because every one of those
wasted dollars is income to somebody uh
you know that's going to be a heavy lift
and I absolutely agree that it's got to
be done it can be done without leaving
people without medical care for the
pathologies of the welfare state uh the
most effective welfare program to avoid
creating perverse incentives and the
most successful of the lot is the Earned
Income Tax Credit which uh in which the
marginal tax rate for an additional
dollar isn't defeating to anybody who
wants to earn an additional dollar for
in some of our welfare programs people
it'll cost you more money to get a
better job in terms of lost welfare
benefits than what you get from your job
that stuff needs to get cleaned up so
I'm perfectly happy to agree that
there's quite a lot of waste in these
programs on the other hand it's a rich
country we can afford to take care of
our old people we can afford to have
social security uh but the threshold
question raised by the Libertarians that
I'm trying to answer in the book is the
question of whether redistribution is
per se immoral because it takes away
from the takers and gives the money to
the Moochers that's the argument that
I'm primarily trying to respond to in
the book but it's not Gene's argument so
I can't have that argument here so uh Mr
Epstein
buddy
as I try to remind you buddy when
somebody asks a question the other
person can can answer the clicking over
but I'm Anton would you allow me to
comment on the answer that he just gave
that's what the moderate is supposed to
allow buddy yeah is that all right I I
intend to but I intend to but I want to
throw in a little twist oh on your
comment which is which is is there any
level of a safety net particularly a
federally sponsored safety net that you
would endorse uh Saturday sponsor for
safety net look there's no look this
look there's no question that the the
medical system in this country and the
welfare system is essentially a tribute
to the insights of public Choice Theory
it was it was not designed in terms of
from Andrew's standpoint to do any real
good it was essentially designed the way
the way those who run the government in
League with other businesses wanted it
designed uh that's the the the the
welfare system is obviously despite the
the lip service that is being paid has
been paid to the idea of giving people
more Independence getting them back on
their feet helping people uh to to
achieve independence in the the market
economy it's done exactly the reverse we
have had since Obamacare was instituted
strangely enough life expectancy has
declined there might be some connection
there you would have expected such a
massive revolution in medical care for
so many millions of people life
expectancy certainly shouldn't have uh
should have risen or at least flattened
it declined so my only point is that
ultimately ultimately the problems that
Libertarians would have to face in
trying to reform this system are quite
complex but ideally ideally there has
always been social welfare for the poor
I've always been prior to the Advent of
the government a myth an unfortunate
myth of progressives is that government
programs came in to play because there
were inadequacies in the way the private
sector was handling the problem there
were Community Hospitals for poor people
doctors Physicians felt the obligation
to do pro bono work at these Community
Hospitals for poor people before the
medical care exploded uh when when
Lyndon Johnson came in uh the the the
fundamental problem with redistribution
is that it's shafting the poor people of
the world because it keeps immigrants
out that by the way is a fundamental
flaw in the philosophy of John Rawls
about redistribution rules was
indifferent to the real problem of of
poverty the poverty of the world and the
Glorious history of the U.S in allowing
immigrants and to achieve a better life
has been stymied by the welfare state so
if in fact we have had if you just look
at what happened in the 19th century we
had mutual Aid societies voluntary Aid
societies charity up the kazoo there
would be plenty of provision for the
poor under those circumstances but with
so you're asking me about the ultimate
question but as it happens and the forms
that Andrew wants are very unlikely to
occur because he's working from a model
that assumes that government wants to do
it better whether government is capable
of doing it better the federal budget is
on the road to Hell Obama did nothing
about it Bush did nothing about it Biden
is doing nothing about it and now of
course we're facing a a crisis with
respect to raising the debt so that's
the difference between me and him
yeah
I guess I just want to say one more time
are you okay with doing away with the
whole Federal welfare thing private
sector I thought I thought I I thought I
answered that okay but but no excuse me
but I want to say that you know when Ron
Paul was running for office he said what
do you do on the first day what do you
do on the first hundred days can you are
we gonna pretend we live a chance that
we simply want the status quo minus
those welfare programs no that's not our
vision we have to build a better society
and a better economy the only the only
thing I would Grant to Andrew by the way
about that one moment was when the
Republicans forced Clinton to try to
reform the welfare welfare policies in
1996. the the the the acts that Clinton
pushed to get people off welfare that
was a push in the right direction which
caught which got nipped in the blood and
thwarted pretty quickly partly by
Republicans as well so so but ultimately
yes ultimately the the society and the
poor would will thrive in a free market
economy without any of these
redistributive programs that only Foster
poverty by supporting dependency
okay
I I have one one last question for uh
for Andrew before we move to the
audience uh in your presentation climate
change and the government as uh as uh
unnecessary or the only way of
addressing this is is an important part
of what you were talking about
um
as as you may know the EPA and other
government agencies under under Biden
have been given a mandate to
get out there and Tackle this problem in
every way possible and
particularly with the EPA not just also
other agencies and states there are lots
of major things which are not like
regulate industry to do it better but
specifically addressed the freedom of
the people and what they can and can't
do that are coming down and I'm talking
about uh forced electrification of
automobiles I'm talking about forced
electric electrification of heat which
Jane was talking about I'm talking about
um
uh the attack on animal husbandry which
is becoming a big thing uh in Europe now
and is coming to this country I'm I'm my
last my own blog post was about uh what
they call virtual power plants which
means
ridiculous orwellian term they're gonna
they're gonna have the control over your
thermostat and turn it off on the
coldest day or on the hottest day
um
do you feel these things are appropriate
should the should the government be
undertaking these kind of restrictions
on on freedom in the name of climate
change
well as I've said before I'm not
prepared to bless everything that
government does the large threshold
question is whether pollution which
climate change is an example of is
something that the free market can
handle and you know if I
carbon emissions warm up the planet you
know let's just stipulate that that's
happening uh there's nobody you can sue
there's too many emitters there's so at
the era Market isn't able to take care
of this so some government solution is
the only way now I suppose you can say
with the public Choice Theory know all
of the government actors are corrupt but
it's an over generalization that
sometimes the case that governments are
corrupt sometimes they're not even
minimal State Libertarians generally
Envision a police force that's not
corrupt there's uh
I understand the anarchists have a
different view uh but so uh so it's just
too much of an over generalization here
but I'm absolutely not I mean I'm it's
quite useful to point to this or that
government program and say that it's
badly done but it's not a problem that
uh the market by itself is going to fix
well Mr episode do you have a do you
have a comment on that Mr Epstein well
again again I I Andrew with expect to
all the things you listed buddy about
what our government is doing I do think
that they're pretty hopeless but of
course as you know and many people in
the audience know as I as I've repeated
it simply is is not going to happen as
again ludicrously New Yorkers have have
one of among the smallest carbon
Footprints and and now they're going to
impose blackouts on poor people in order
to reduce the carbon footprint further
other localities are not doing it and
certainly again all you have to do is
look up the statements or even read the
New York Times India Bangladesh China
Africa they are not going along with it
so it's it's it's it's it's ludicrous on
its face even assuming that it can work
out in the United States with respect to
the larger issue that Andrew poses of
course he's talking about the Dilemma
faced by uh or am I in and cap am I a
minicus all of those questions or
questions we could get into but of
course even of course and caps do
believe in the rule of law they think
the private Market can can Institute it
and but I'm I'm not by the way I I don't
think that if climate change were a
problem and come and we really were
facing uh you know 50 Degree heating of
the planet and and it's going to be
unlivable unless we do something then
there could be a class action suit a
class action suit is messy but again I
put it to Andrew that those
bureaucracies those regulatory agencies
are also messy class action suits would
involve experts nobody not neither
Libertarians nor uh status if Andrew
will forgive me for calling him a status
compared to me certainly uh have have a
good solution to these problems with
respect to externalities but certainly
libertarian solution of a class action
suit is perfectly feasible and very
likely to work out better than having an
entrenched bureaucracy that always needs
to do something in order to keep itself
employed bureaucracies want to do less
want to do I want to do less with them
with more they have bad incentives so
probably uh working it out through the
courts and through class action suits is
a better solution to the problem that's
the libertarian solution
okay with that I think we should move to
audience questions and uh uh I see
there's a group of people lined up could
you uh uh please try to make it a
question try to make it fairly brief so
that the uh people can answer it quickly
and other people can have a turn
the question was for Gene Epstein but it
was on externalities and I'm just
wondering let's say forget climate
change let's say River pollution
how do you think that would be handled
if there was no government
like how would we deal with the
externality well again uh you see the
now we're getting into sort of the uh
the the plumbing the depths of of uh of
agricultism or of or of uh minicky uh uh
anarchists insists that there would be
rule of law and then uh Murray rothbud
wrote a book called ethics of Liberty
about the laws and and and codes under
an advocate Society so certainly
pollution is an externality that that
offends the zero aggression principle
the Libertarians the spouse and it would
be a legitimate offense uh to the law
and therefore there could be action to
the courts I I totally agree with Andrew
that that uh these these situations are
messy determining the outcome is messy
but again if you compare it with the
alternative putting a bureaucracy in
charge of it all the time that
bureaucracy could do Mischief in order
to keep itself busy and I submit to
Andrew that that's exactly what has been
happening so again uh the rule of law is
something all Libertarians accept and uh
and and externality uh offends the rule
it violates the law having to do with
zero aggression and that would be the
solution
thank you Alan Mandel here two brief
questions both for Andrew number one why
aren't you aware of the super El Nino
that is formed in the equatorial Pacific
which is anticipated to bring
catastrophic effects around the world
and there are 48 active volcanoes on the
planet including Krakatoa the last time
40 years ago there was a super Krakatoa
volcano the Earth's temperature was
reduced by 1.5 degrees and there are
five volcanoes in the United States
Hawaii and the Aleutian Islands so why
don't you know that and incorporate that
into your models second and even briefer
on the Federal Reserve on the federal
return don't you think I'll use Gene's
term don't you think don't you think
that the Federal Reserve has no clue
that raising interest rates does not
bring inflation down and that lowering
interest rates does not help wages keep
up with inflation that they Don don't
know what they're doing and they're jaw
boning in order to try and influence the
markets
uh well I'm I think that I'm simply not
going to speak to uh the climate model
uh I will say that uh I mean the
question of whether humans are
generating climate change uh I'm just
going to have to leave it as an exercise
to the audience uh you know I'm a
political philosopher it seems to me
that the evidence of man-made climate
change is massive and catastrophic but I
mean that's all that I can say about
that on the question of whether the
Federal Reserve has been ruining the U.S
economy in the 20th century all I'll say
is that the U.S economy has been
performing at a much higher level than
the economy of other Advanced industrial
countries if you compare our growth with
that of you of England or France or
Germany
um we seem to do pretty well despite the
fact that the pernicious Federal Reserve
is dragging us down now I suppose you
can always say yeah but without the
Federal Reserve it would just be amazing
and all I can say is that no actual
world can compete with the fantasy
worlds we can conjure up
again I remind Andrew
I did a before and after
before not not with an imaginary world
but with a before World there is very
good data about the performance of the
US economy in the in the in the last
half of the uh the 19th century and into
the 20th up through 1913. it was
troubled by by state intervention of all
kinds Banks were not permitted to branch
and actually actually laws against
branching prevailed until the 90s if a
bank can't Branch it can't it can't
reduce risk so Banks were having
problems all kinds of problems existed
the U.S economy was way ahead of the ma
of the rest of the world in the 19th
century and into the 20th prior to the
creation of the Federal Reserve and
again the usual myth that's perpetrated
is that the Federal Reserve was created
in order to solve a problem read uh read
the book about the meeting on Jekyll
Island and you'll realize that it arose
from crony capitalism Canada did not
have a Federal Reserve until well into
the 30s and did far better so again I'm
I'm grounding this in a before and after
a simple before and after to talk about
the Federal Reserve even if you forgive
the Federal Reserve the Great Depression
which happened 13 was it I'm sorry
actually it happened 16 years after the
Federal Reserve was created even if you
take it the last 50 years it did no
better in terms of boom and boom and
bust than uh than the economy did prior
to the creation of the Federal Reserve
inflation price inflation which we're
going through now has been far worse so
that's where the FED gets lower marks
and then ironically ironically Andrew is
a champion of Friedrich Hayek and
Friedrich Hayek won a Nobel Prize in
part specifically credited for his
insights into how the Federal Reserve
exacerbates business Cycles
next question my question is for Andrew
greed delusion and disdain for the week
these were
exampled by you in Obamacare and in
climate change
Obamacare was a program where people buy
private insurance they're forced to buy
private insurance and climate change is
a series of reforms of purchasing new
products on the private Market as we see
with these electrical heaters
do you not think that there's greed in
these companies that are forcing these
new changes these uh either whether it's
Obamacare the the insurance mandates or
whether it's whether it's the climate
change
and should Libertarians not be skeptical
of that greed just as you might be a
skeptical of the the greed that is
promoting libertarian ideas
well greed is a constant of human
psychology the specific
point that I made by using that in uh
the title of the book is that the desire
to dismantle government agencies I'm
particularly concerned about regulatory
agencies that deal with externalities
like pollution it's hard for me to
imagine what the class actions suit uh
that Gina's imagining I don't know all
victims of carbon emissions against all
carbon emitters
um what that would look like but uh what
you what I've actually seen with the
Restriction with the effort to restrict
government bureaucracies is a coalition
between idealists like Gene who want to
uh reduce uh government because they
really think it will make people better
off and industries that are whose
profits would be reduced if they were
required to reduce their pollution
preeminently they
car the fossil fuel industry who would
really like very much to be allowed to
hurt people without being bothered by
the police that's the kind of greed that
concerns me
uh uh just a brief comment uh I cited
Eisenhower
who talked about the military-industrial
complex and the dangers thereof and who
predicted that there was a danger of
endless Wars
um Eisenhower was not a Libertarian uh
and uh maybe he was an idealist like me
uh in the sense that Andrew means but
Eisenhower dearly wanted that rollback
of the military-industrial complex
exactly the opposite happened and we
have been living we are now at a at a
point where we we have increasing danger
of nuclear war with Russia uh that's uh
I think Eisenhower would be rolling over
in his grave and he was not a
libertarian
yeah next question yes this question is
for Epstein go into the topic of
government intervention and climate
change regulation do you also think that
India's commitment to net zero emissions
by 2070 is misguided
laughs
uh I commend the New York Times to you
and also non-libertarian publication uh
that said that that that quoted uh
leading politicians leading uh uh those
who lead the economy in India all of
whom when they are really asked about it
specifically say that yes we are
building coal-fired plants yes do you
know where all the the oil that Russia
could not sell has been sold to India's
been buying it gobbling it up and so you
will certainly find that uh if if you
quote them out of context they're going
to pay lip service uh to what the big
rulers of the world in the U.S want them
to say they'll be polite about it but
look at what they're doing not what
they're saying although indeed look
occasionally at what they're saying and
you'll find that they are saying that
fossil fuels are the ticket for their
people out of poverty
okay we have time for about one or two
more questions
you're next sir
uh this is for Andrew
um you seem to Tout The vaccine as well
as certain other uh government agencies
responses to crises as being quite
successful whereas numerous Studies have
come out and shown that the vaccine is
quite ineffective and basically
worthless and has caused all kinds of
various heart issues and you also
pointed to the Potomac as an example of
a I assume the EPA being successful
can you name a single uh executive
regulatory agency that has not been
captured by uh special interest
if uh well if you want an example of a
regulation that uh
the uh
I mean one of the problems here is that
government agencies they are enormously
large and complicated things very hard
to uh generalize about them but uh one
significant environmental regulation
that came out of the Obama
Administration was the restriction on
fine particulates uh that is uh bits of
soot that are so tiny that they can
cross the blood brain barrier they uh
shorten the lives of old people they
cause brain damage in infants uh and uh
you know they imposed enormous costs on
industry but uh the same time those
enormous costs were uh imposed you know
the administration the Trump
Administration subsequently ran a
cost-benefit analysis on this regulation
of the Obama Administration and
concluded that the benefits would
outweighed the costs and the costs were
in billions the benefits outweighed the
costs by a factor of four or five I
don't know how without government
regulation you could have reached the
same result
well again I guess Andrew
um Andrew said that he doesn't know how
I'm talking to a law professor and so uh
I'm not I guess I'm I'm on thin ice here
but uh doesn't know how a class action
suit would work uh or how uh any kind of
lawsuit would work about harm that's
being done you know as as uh as rothberg
wrote actually in in for a new Liberty
we talk about air pollution but that's
just pollution just through the air it's
polluting our throats it's polluting our
people our persons and so it's clearly a
tort it is a harm and the idea that
that's hopeless is I I don't see why
it's hopeless uh to to bring that kind
of case a million people sign on with a
class action suit it's reviewed let's
say it's appealed uh what do they do
excuse me every Power every emitter in
the country well all the major emitters
these lawsuits are out there currently
you can read about them on them
where I have cool told them the
stupidest lawsuits in the country but
I I think I think our moderator just got
a little bit too in moderate there and
um but uh but yeah the you you bring
again I I readily agree with you Andrew
that these things are messy you may you
name the major polluters and and and and
uh and and a lot of people sign on to
and and of course it's reviewed experts
testify and that's how it gets resolved
now you agreed that a government is
messy it's complicated I suggest you
read a book called uh why government
fails so often uh the uh it it does one
thing right let's say that was done
right what you just cited could it have
been done the libertarian way I say yes
of course it could have yeah
final question sir
uh thank you very much so this is a
question for both uh Andrew and Gene uh
to challenge some of your uh statements
on climate change both of you so since
the 1980s since the Reagan tax cuts of
the 1980s there were a couple of very
environmentally beneficial tax cuts that
produce major changes accelerated
depreciation reduced the cost of
installing property plant and Equipment
they found that because of that Energy
Efficiency Investments penciled out and
you saw people putting in a lot more new
equipment which made all the equipment
more efficient you saw energy use per
capita decoupled from GDP you also saw
Reagan implemented conservation easement
tax deductions which resulted in the
growth of uh you know 33 million Acres
of trees on private land since that time
so when you say there's no free market
kind of policies that you can use to
combat climate
that's clearly untrue because obviously
that there are things that you can do
that that you know result in innovation
in the United States reducing its fossil
it's its emissions enormously
by free market means so
for you Andrew when you say that the
Koch brothers have uh you know used
climate skepticism as a Libertarian tool
to derail uh you know American politics
isn't that untrue I mean climate
skepticism isn't an economic policy it's
a scientific policy so it's not even
libertarianism it's it's a scientific
it's not it has nothing to do with free
market policy and Gene you know when you
say you know gee we have to use fossil
fuels uh you know almost exclusively you
know aren't you ignoring aren't you kind
of stepping off the free market bus
entirely by picking winners and losers
and not realizing that innovation
is what's really important and that you
know the kinds of energy we use 10 or 20
years from now may look incredibly
different because of that power of
innovation
so uh so I certainly don't want to
condemn Market Solutions uh the uh the
question is whether a completely
unregulated free market which means that
I get to poison my neighbors and they
don't get to do anything about it
because uh you know as it happens I you
know I guess we have a disagreement
about the capacities of class action
suits to remedy very tiny harms to large
numbers of people uh that's just a
disagreement about how the legal system
works but uh The Innovation that was
proposed in the 1990s that I think is
the most hayekian is to have a carbon
tax that just tells industry all right
let us have you incorporate the full
costs of what you're doing and if you
can come up with a cleaner uh energy uh
solution to this problem something with
a smaller carbon Footprints you'll
out-compete your competitors and you'll
make money and that's how the market
works we create incentives for people to
uh come up with Innovations and that is
how progress has in fact happened that
would have been the hayekian solution to
some extent you're still seeing it
um yeah that's my best answer to your
question uh is this uh is that uh just
uh that indeed obviously Innovation is
vital uh but uh speaking of somebody
who's covered the economy who's written
about the oil markets as a journalist
for many years uh I look at the fact
that that North America U.S Mexico
Canada if they simply allowed uh all of
the oil that's available via fracking uh
and also on land Zone by the U.S to
flourish and if you're up uh Europe has
about 50 years worth of oil and gas if
it's simply tapped all of the reserves
in France needn't be dependent on either
OPEC or on Russia all of those things
are possible fossil fuels are looks as
though uh the India and China and Africa
are recognizing that the best bet is
fossil fuels for the Next Generation but
of course I readily Grant to you that
Innovation could change that it just
doesn't look as though it's likely to
happen given the pace of integration
even if we had a free market for another
generation of 2050 2060 uh I think
probably the future is nuclear
all right thanks to all the questioners
and we are now
we are now going to move to the Final
Phase of our debate a five-minute
wrap up from each of the participants Mr
koppelman
you have the floor
you can you can use the podium or the
chair it's up to you I'm happy to take
the chair here uh so uh I mean there's a
I will say there's a range of issues
that uh you know it's hard to put them
under a single rubric the issues raised
by uh American foreign policy are
different from the issues raised by
climate change which are different from
uh the issues raised by the Federal
Reserve uh which are issues that I
frankly didn't talk about in the book uh
the uh
I will say uh that the reason why we've
had so much Prosperity one of the points
that Adam Smith makes in The Wealth of
Nations is that people tend to innovate
people tend to produce people tend to
produce gains from trade in a world
where there is law where there are
reliable rules and so uh I guess what
troubles me about the idea of an
isolationist foreign policy which has
been repeatedly suggested here is that
uh you all of the prosperity we've had
in the last couple of hundred years have
happened since the Napoleonic Wars when
uh except During the period between
World War II which between the world
wars which was not that great you have
had a policeman of the planet I don't
think that Eisenhower would have been
enthusiastic about allowing Russia to
gobble up Ukraine nor do I think he
would have been enthusiastic about
allowing China to gobble up Taiwan uh I
don't think that those events in the
return to a world in which nations
gobble up one another as they can would
have been good for business
um
and uh you know beyond that uh on the
consequences of this or that government
policy which is uh We've jumped across a
number of them I'm entirely open to
Market Solutions uh you know again you
know a carbon tax is a market-based
solution the question is whether you
want to have these government agencies
at all or whether the hypothesis that
this or that uh activity could be better
done by the private sector is a
rebuttable empirical presumption that is
going to be dependent on evidence and
dependent on the ways in which we can
enlist the private sector or not the
last thing that I'll say just about the
uh climate question and the question of
the development of third world countries
is that those third world countries are
going to make the transition to Green
energy if green and if cheap green
energy is devised and handed to them on
a platter the Chinese will steal it uh
and uh that it but that's only going to
happen if there is massive investment in
green energy that massive investment has
happened in the past it's happening
right now and it's largely driven by the
federal government
Mr Epstein five minutes
take the podium
well we've been talking about
consequentialism uh for much of the
evening uh Andrew has humored me by
addressing some of the consequentialist
points that I I made uh and uh I'm uh
hopefully brought across the point that
the uh the U.S Wars of choice uh Andrew
himself talked about clumsy disasters in
Iraq uh Afghanistan and uh and Vietnam
so he he's already uh talking about
millions of lives lost in those Wars so
he already seems to agree that we
Libertarians have a point I listed all
of the uh ferocious the the murderous
things that Obama did focusing on him
especially because Obama seems to be a
president that Andrew has mostly gives a
like a a b plus over an A minus two you
know he has a few problems with Obama I
talked about the lockdowns uh the uh
there are there have been hundreds of
thousands of people who've died in third
world countries partly because of the
lockdowns that we impose that that uh
that screwed up Supply chains the fact
that we were not traveling to these
countries to help them with vaccines the
disasters from the lockdowns have been
enormous and uh and and as well when
Andrew talks about how we are going to
uh turn uh green energy
Renewables I think he said wind and sun
or at least he's alluded to wind and Sun
how those intermittent unreliable
sources of energy are ever going to
become cheap well it doesn't seem as
though it's in the cards it doesn't seem
as though it's going to happen the only
other I guess additional point that I
have to to introduce is that there has
been great doubt shed by those who look
at the climate models about what how
what to what extent we are causing
global warming clearly our greenhouse
gas CO2 is a cause but we do know that
one of the fastest periods of global
warming occurred from 1910 to 1940 and
it wasn't until the middle of the of the
20th century that uh that uh that
greenhouse gases began to become a
factor so we know that the many natural
forces and that's the fundamental
problem with the carbon tax the truth is
that even though William nordhaus won a
Nobel Prize for talking about a carbon
tax which by the way would have been a
relatively modest tax
according to most standards it was
unfortunately based on the assumption
that we actually know precisely to what
extent we are causing global warming it
could be 10 it's probably considerably
less than 50 percent so my my I
mentioned that only because again we
know that for the foreseeable future the
the world the the poor people of the
world are dying for lack of fossil fuels
and uh and they and they're making uh
sensible strides toward acquiring them
again that's been the secret where's
where's that Soviet Russian oil been
going it's been going to India so again
we're talking about not not minor
problems with the way our government
runs the world we are talking about
major issues threats to life and Liberty
I didn't even get a chance to talk about
all the ways in which for example Jay
bhattacharya Jay bhattacharya who was a
spokesperson against the lockdowns was
through government intervention he was
shut out of Twitter we we have an
assault by the government and on a
Twitter Facebook Bear In Mind One Thing
those who run Twitter and Facebook they
make their money they make their money
by allowing in the greatest number of
users possible their motivation is to
allow all everybody in that's how they
make their money that's how they sell
their advertising so that's not their
incentive we have an assault on our
freedom of speech from the government
because because the powers that be are
upset about about our use of freedom of
speech on these platforms that's another
fight Libertarians are waging as well so
there are a whole lot of important
battles that we Libertarians want to
wage against our government and I I hope
I can enlist the Brilliance of my friend
Andrew koppelman in supporting those
efforts thank you very much
[Applause]
well let me thank our two excellent
Debaters tonight for their
really
fine and focused presentations
uh the time has come
for the final vote
well take your no no I'm gonna I'm gonna
filibuster here for a minute so
so everybody it's time to vote and while
you're voting it's my turn to filibuster
I'm going to filibuster with the
upcoming events of the Soho Forum Soho
forum is going to pork fest in New
Hampshire June 19 to 25 so that's coming
right up
and they have two debates there
according to this information that Gene
has handed me
so the first one the resolution is
the right way to persuade people of
libertarianism is by showing them that
its outcomes are superior without any
resort to the flawed non-aggression
principle
for the affirmative David Friedman
that's Milton Friedman's son and uh also
a blogger in his own right and the
negative will be oh Gene Epstein once
again
so and that he doesn't give me a
specific date for that but it's at pork
fest and also at pork fest here is
another resolution
uh this is a little more entertaining
it's easier to convert a heterosexual to
homosexuality than it is to convert a
non-libertarian to libertarianism
and that for that proposition will be
the affirmative will be taken by Jeremy
Kaufman the negative
by Matt Kibby
here at the sheen Center the next Soho
forum debate will be January 25.
uh January excuse me July I was off by
just a little July 25 so we'll make it
the hottest time of the year instead of
the coldest and uh so the resolution
will be the U.S should have free
immigration except for those who pose a
security threat or have serious
contagious disease for the affirmative
will be Alex norasti he is a senior
fellow at the Cato Institute which I
think came in for some criticism in
today's debate and for the negative that
would be myself Manhattan contrarian
blogger Francis menten for the negative
on that one
on Monday August 21 the resolution
today's school choice movement in the
U.S is worthy of support by Libertarians
uh for the affirmative Corey DeAngelis
for the negative Stephen kinsella and
finally Monday September 18.
the resolution and Narco capitalism
would definitely be a complete disaster
for Humanity
for that one the affirmative will be
taken by yaron Brooke
and the negative by Brian Kaplan and
I've got one more here Monday October
16.
the resolution is between now and 2035
electric vehicles in the consumer Market
will disappoint environmentalists by
remaining a product bought mainly by the
well-heeled minority for the affirmative
Mark Mills for the negative Rosario
fortuno
so that is upcoming I've given you the
next six for the Soho Forum we hope to
see you all at all of them Jane Benton
is the voting complete
the voting results now I got to get this
in a light where I can read it let's see
for the affirmative
uh pre
vote pre-debate 15 percent
were in favor of it
uh post debate 14 wait a minute
he lost a point but only one point for
the negative
uh pre-debate 35 percent post-debate
65 percent whoa they gained the voting
[Applause]
oh
yeah
he came into the lion's den and
uh Gene gave me a Tootsie Roll But I
don't I don't think I can give it to the
proprietor no I forgot it I forgot it so
I'm gonna have to get another Tootsie
Roll that Soho Forum Tootsie Roll I'm
gonna get one over at Gene's apartment
after the event out of your salary buddy
Tootsie Roll from Gene and give it to
him congratulations gene on your
brilliant Victory and thank you all for
coming I turn it back over to Gene